PROFESSOR: In this
segment, we will
look at the famous
example, which
was posed by Comte de Buffon--
a French naturalist--
back in the 18th century.
And it marks the
beginning of a subject
that is known as the subject
of geometric probability.
The problem is pretty simple.
We have the infinite
plane, and we
draw lines that are
parallel to each other.
And they're spaced
apart d units.
So this distance here is d.
And the same for
all the other lines.
We take a needle that has
a certain length-- l--
and we throw it at
random on the plane.
So the needle might
fall this way, so
that it doesn't cross any line,
or it might fall this way,
so that it ends up
crossing one of the lines.
If the needle is long enough,
it might actually even end up
crossing two of the lines.
But we will make the assumption
that the length of the needle
is less than the distance
between the two--
between two adjacent
lines, so that we're
going to have either
this configuration,
or that configuration.
So in this setting, we're
interested in the question
of how likely is it that the
needle is going to intersect
one of the lines if the needle
is thrown completely at random?
We will answer this question,
and we will proceed as follows.
First, we need to
model the experiment--
the probabilistic
experiment-- mathematically.
That is, we need to define
an appropriate sample space,
define some relevant
random variables,
choose an appropriate
probability law,
identify the event of
interest, and then calculate.
Let us see what it takes to
describe a typical outcome
of the experiment.
Suppose that the needle fell
this way, so that the nearest
line is the one above.
And let us mark here the
center of the needle.
One quantity of interest
is this vertical distance
between the needle
and the nearest line.
Let us call this quantity x.
We're using here a
lowercase x, because we're
dealing with a numerical value
in one particular outcome
of the experiment.
But we think of this x
as being the realization
of a certain random
variable that we
will denote by capital X.
What else does it take
to describe the needle?
Suppose that the
needle had fallen
somewhere so that it is at
the same vertical distance
from the nearest
line, but it has
an orientation of this kind.
This orientation
compared to that one
should make a difference.
Because when it falls
that way, it's more likely
that it's going to cut the next
line as opposed to this case.
So the angle that the needle is
making with the parallel lines
should also be relevant.
So let us give a name to
that particular angle.
So let's extend that line until
it crosses one of the lines.
And let us give a name to
this angle, and call it theta.
So if I tell you
x and theta, you
know how far away the needle
is from the nearest line,
and at what angle it is.
It looks like these are
two useful variables
to describe the outcome
of the experiment, so let
us try working with these.
So our model is going to involve
two random variables defined
the way we discussed
it just now.
What is the range of
these random variables?
Since we took x to be the
distance from the nearest line,
and the lines are
d units apart, this
means that x is going to
be somewhere between 0
and d over 2.
How about theta?
So the needle makes two angles
with the part of the line.
It's this angle, and
the complimentary one.
Which one do we take?
Well, we use a
convention that theta
is defined as the acute
angle that the direction
of the needle is
making with the lines,
so that theta will vary over
a range from 0 to pi over 2.
And our sample space
for the experiments
who will be the set of
all pairs of x and theta,
that satisfy these
two conditions.
These will be the
possible x's and thetas.
Having defined the
sample space, next we
need to define a
probability law.
At this point, we do not want to
make any arbitrary assumptions.
We only have the words
completely at random to go by.
But what do these words mean?
We will interpret them to mean
that there are no preferred x
values, so that all x
values are- in some sense--
equally likely.
So we're going to assume that
x is a uniform random variable.
Since it is uniform,
it's going to be
a constant over this range.
And in order to integrate
to 1, that constant
will have to be 2 over d.
And we understand that the PDF
of x is 0 outside that range.
Similarly for theta,
we do not want
to assume that some
orientations are more
likely than other orientations.
So we will again assume
a uniform probability
distribution.
And therefore, that PDF
must be equal to 2 over pi
for theta's over this
particular range.
So far, we have specified
the marginal PDFs of each one
of the two random variables.
How about the adjoined PDF?
In order to have
a complete model,
we need to have a
joint PDF in our hands.
Here, we're going to make the
assumption that x and theta are
independent of each other.
And in that case,
the joint PDF is
determined by just taking the
product of the marginal PDFs.
So the joint PDF is
going to be equal to 4
divided by pi times d.
By this point, we
have completely
specified a probabilistic model.
We have made some assumptions,
which you might even
consider arbitrary.
But these assumptions
are a reasonable attempt
at capturing the idea
that the needle is
thrown completely at random.
This completes the
subjective part--
the modeling part.
The next step is much
more streamlined.
There's not going
to be any choices.
We just need to consider
the event of interest,
express it in terms of
the random variables
that we have in our hands, and
then use the probability model
that we have to
calculate the probability
of this particular event.
So let us identify
the event of interest.
When will the needle
intersect the nearest line?
This will depend
on the following.
We can look at the vertical
extent of the needle.
By vertical extent,
I mean the following.
Let's see how far
the needle goes
in the vertical direction,
which is the length
of this green segment here.
In this example, the
vertical extent of the needle
is less than the distance
from the next line.
And we do not have
an intersection.
If the figure was
something like this,
the vertical extent of the
needle would have been that,
but x would have been
just this little segment.
The vertical extent is
bigger than x and the needle
intersects the line.
So we have an
intersection if and only
if the vertical extent--
which is this vertical
green segment--
is larger than the distance x.
Or equivalently, if x is less
than the vertical extent.
So we will have an
intersection if x is less than
or equal to the vertical
extent of the needle.
Now, how big is this
vertical extent?
Let's use some
trigonometry here.
This angle here is theta, so
this angle here is also theta.
Here, we have a right
triangle and the hypotenuse
of this triangle is l over 2.
This angle is theta, therefore
this vertical segment
is equal to l over
2 times sine theta.
So this is the
geometrical condition
that describes the event
that the needle intersects
the nearest line.
And all we need to do
now is to calculate
the probability of this event.
So here is what we have so far.
This is the picture that
we had before, but drawn
in a somewhat nicer way.
This is the joint PDF
that we decided upon.
And we wish to calculate
the probability
of this particular event--
that x is less than or equal
to l over 2 sine theta.
How do we calculate
the probability
of an event that has to do
with two random variables?
What we do is we
take the joint PDF--
which in our case
is four over pi d--
and integrate it over the set
of x's and theta's for which
the PDF is non-zero.
So it's only going to be over
x's and theta's in those ranges
and also, only for
those x theta pairs
for which the event occurs.
So what are these pairs?
This event can occur
with any choice of theta.
So theta is free to vary
from 0 up to pi over 2.
How about x?
For this event to
occur, x can be
anything that is non-negative
as long as it is less than
or equal to this number.
So the upper limit
of this integration
is going to be l over
2 times sine theta.
And all we need to do now is to
evaluate this double integral.
Let's start with
the inner integral.
Because we're just
integrating a constant,
the inner integral
evaluates to the quantity
that we're integrating--
the constant that we're
integrating-- which is 4
times pi d times the length
of the interval over
which we're integrating,
which is l over 2 sine theta.
And now we need to carry
out the outer integral.
Let us pull out the constants,
which is this 4 with this 2
give us a 2.
We have 2l over pi d.
And then the integral from 0
to pi over 2 of sine theta.
Now the integral of sine
theta is minus cosine theta.
And we need to evaluate
this at 0 and pi over 2.
This turns out to be equal to 1.
So the final result
is 2 l over pi d.
And this is the final
answer to the problem
that we have been considering.
And now, a curious thought.
Suppose that you do not
know what the number pi is
and all you have
in your hands is
your floor, lines drawn on
your floor, and the needle.
And you do know the length
between adjacent lines
on your floor.
And you do know your
length of your needle.
How can you figure
out the number pi?
Take your needle, throw it
at random a million times,
and count the frequency with
which the needle ends up
crossing the line.
If you believe
that probabilities
can be interpreted
as frequencies,
the frequency that you observe
gives you a good estimate
of this probability.
So it gives you a good estimate
of this particular number.
And if you know the length of
your needle and of the distance
between the different
lines, you can
use the estimate of that number
to determine the value of pi.
This is a so-called
Monte Carlo method,
which uses simulation to
evaluate experimentally
the value, in this case,
of the constant pi.
Of course, for pi, we have much
better ways of calculating it.
But there are many applications
in engineering and in physics
where certain quantities
are hard to calculate,
but they can be calculated
using a trick of this kind
by simulation.
Here's a typical situation.
Consider the unit cube.
And for simplicity,
I'm only taking
a cube in two dimensions.
But in general, think
of the unit cube
in n dimensions, which is an
object that has unit volume.
Inside that unit cube, there
is a complicated subset
which is described maybe by
some very complicated formulas.
And you want to
calculate the volume
of this complicated subset.
The description of the
subset is so complicated
that using integration,
multiple integrals, and calculus
is practically impossible.
What can you do?
What you can do is to start
throwing at random points
inside that unit cube.
So you throw points.
Some fault inside.
Some fall outside.
You count the frequency
with which the points
happen to be inside your set.
And as long as you're
throwing the points uniformly
over the cube, then
the probability
of your complicated set is going
to be the volume of that set.
You estimate the
probability by counting
the frequency with which
you get points in that set.
And so, by using these
observed frequencies,
you can estimate the
volume of a set--
something that might
be very difficult to do
through other numerical methods.
It turns out that these days,
physicists and many engineers
use methods of this
kind quite often
and in many important
applications.